i am so excited because this video is
going to be a blind reaction i have not
seen this video it's all about ovulation
but let's watch it together
[Music]
ovulation is a part of the menstrual
cycle when the ovary releases a ripe egg
or ovum
inside the ovary are hundreds of
thousands of follicles
each follicle is a hollow ball of cells
with an immature egg in the center
the typical already i am so obsessed
with this animation
unbelievable i loved how it showed just
going in straight into the pelvis you
can see the uterus and how the fallopian
tubes lay how the ovaries are you can
see the close relationship between the
fallopian tube and the ovary
this is amazing critical 28-day
menstrual cycle begins on the first day
of menstrual bleeding
during the first seven days of the cycle
i quickly want to pause it right there
because i get this question all the time
as an ob gyn when we talk about your
last menstrual period or when your
doctor asks you when your last menstrual
period was
we want to know day one of when you
started bleeding day one of your
menstrual cycle is the first day that
you see blood seven days of the cycle a
few follicles begin to grow at the same
time
these maturing follicles secrete
estrogen hormone into the bloodstream to
prepare the lining of the uterus for
pregnancy
around day seven all of the follicles
stop growing and begin to degenerate
except for one
this dominant follicle can so did you
hear that they said around day seven
that's when the follicles all stopped
growing so this correlates to day seven
of the menstrual cycle that is why we
typically like to divide the menstrual
cycle into two phases one and two the
first phase is called the follicular
phase as they're talking about in this
video this is when the follicles are all
forming follicular phase follicles and
nourishes the developing egg inside
it around day 12 the follicle secretes a
large amount of estrogen into the
bloodstream
when the estrogen reaches the
hypothalamus and the pituitary gland in
the brain the anterior or front part of
the pituitary gland releases a huge
surge of luteinizing hormone into the
bloodstream
around day 14 luteinizing hormone causes
the follicle to undergo a sudden growth
spurt
right before ovulation the egg detaches
from the inside of the follicle
the bulging follicle releases chemicals
causing one of the two fallopian tubes
to move in closer and surround the
follicle
the follicle swells until this is
incredible i think this animation is
amazing real quick i want to talk about
how i love that the video also included
the role of the pituitary gland in the
brain in relation to the menstrual cycle
it's absolutely crazy but the menstrual
cycle is really such a special and
sensitive thing and you need so many
different parts and elements to work
together in order for ovulation to occur
it really is a huge communication system
between your ovary your brain
the uterus the fallopian tube everything
needs to run together in order for this
process to happen the follicle swells
until it bursts open ejecting the egg
and fluid from the follicle into the
abdominal cavity
in response the fimbriae tiny
projections at the end of the fallopian
tube sweep across the ovulation site and
pick up the egg
microscopic cilia on the fimbriae
surface transport the egg to the
entrance of the fallopian tube
inside the walls of the fallopian tube
muscular contractions gently push the
egg towards the uterus
after ovulation the egg lives for 12 to
24 hours so it must be fertilized by i'm
going to stop it right there too isn't
that insane that egg is only alive for
12 to 24 hours so this process of
ovulation is pretty short-lived so when
we start talking about trying to get
pregnant or trying to conceive that is
kind of a tight window there between 12
and 24 hours for everything to line up
perfectly it must be fertilized by a
sperm from the male during this time for
a woman to become pregnant
if it's not fertilized the egg dissolves
away and is shed along with the uterine
lining during menstruation
i absolutely loved this video the
animation is unreal i loved how it
really correlated all the different
parts that need to run together in order
for us to have
one a nice normal regular period also
showing the importance of ovulation when
we start talking about pregnancy you're
not having ovulation and your ovary or
the other ovary isn't spitting out that
egg there's not going to be a chance of
pregnancy i really hope you all enjoyed
this video i thought this animation was
absolutely amazing this video was in
collaboration with nucleus medical media
and my youtube channel alirodmd over on
my youtube channel i've created a fun
space where we talk about all things
women's health please check out my
channel by visiting the link in the
description below i hope you guys have
an amazing week always remember to be
kind and show love to everyone around
you bye